[Musique]
c'est un peu un peu bizarre c'est très
vide donc pas habitué à tout ça
[Musique]
elles font des contrôles et ils
demandent bien l'attestation de
dérogation donc ils ont bien vérifier
aussi du tout pour les prochaines fois
ou bien avoir l'attestation à chaque
sortie et avoir la carte d'identité
aussi
[Musique]
le contrôle je prends très au sérieux je
crois que si chacun y met du sien on
arrivera à quelque chose et certainement
plus vite
c'est très bien il faudrait éradiquer
notons que ce virus et pour cela il faut
que tout le monde se confirme depuis
midi on est en train d'expliquer parce
que manifestement beaucoup de personnes
ont d'ores et déjà compris les messages
du président la république et du
gouvernement puisque voyez les rues sont
quasi vides mais ya encore des personnes
qui ont des questions qu'on est en là à
répondre à des potes à des petites
questions pratiques